Lindsay Lohan has her life back on track
she's got her wild reality show which I
love so much
and a brand new movie that is even
crazier do you miss anything about
Hollywood it's not like I've stopped
just doing things differently someone
wants to kill my husband this certainly
is different in her first leading role
in six years lowens a first lady in a
supernatural political thriller hunting
down werewolves does it burn you that we
have the power in the Federation human
drunks are wolves the part actually
required martial arts training and
Lindsay got crazed from her co-stars
seems like she's trying to up her acting
game to change this image many still
have are you actively looking for
projects or yeah would you consider
moving back to Hollywood no no not not
moved my life no you don't think you had
having my private life private among the
shadows filmed throughout Europe and not
far from Mykonos where the hair flipping
boss lady made her fan obsessed a
reality TV comeback in Lindsay Lohan's
beach club tonight she takes no
prisoners blasted guests with a
champagne gun and keeping an eye out for
slacking staff do you have an end you to
say you're done you're fired get out of
here oh yeah yeah yeah season two we'll
see let's see I hope everyone gets their
season one
[Music]